I think many people including myself
were confused when seeing a mermaid in a
god of war game inspired by Norse
mythology so who is this mysterious Lady
of the Lake there will be spoilers ahead
so if you've yet to finish the game you
have been warned we first encounter the
Lady of the Lake when Brock's planned to
help Kratos defeat heindel is to bind
the magical ring drop near to a weapon
and create a magical spear at the bottom
of the lake we meet this mysterious
mermaid who creates the spear for Kratos
however the process requires the blood
of a God the only Lady of the Lake I had
ever heard of appeared in medieval
literature the most noticeable being in
the story of King Arthur there was also
the movie by M Night Shyamalan after
thinking for a while it made sense the
Lady of the Lake is not from this land
nor is she meant to be there are
numerous examples of folklore from the
British Isles throughout the game mimir
himself is referred to as Puck a fairy
who appears in British and Celtic
folklore he also talks about being from
another land which given his accent is
referring to Scotland it also explains
why when traveling to see the norns and
we encounter a kelpie mimir tells us we
don't often see them in these parts of
the land because they are indeed from
Scottish folklore there are many
iterations of human enchantresses
located around bodies of water in all
sorts of European folklore in the story
of King Arthur he is presented the
magical sword Excalibur by the Lady of
the Lake not too different from the
mermaid presenting Kratos with a magical
spear there are also stories in Greek
mythology where nymphs of the sea
provide Heroes with magical weapons the
mother of Achilles thesis B an example
this may also explain why the writing
team chose to make her a mermaid nymphs
in Greek mythology can sometimes appear
similar I do now have some questions
however regarding Brock and sindri it's
clear this was not the first time they
had visited the Lady of the Lake so how
many of their Creations in the game were
made by her did she make drop near maybe
kratos's ax or even Thor's hammer I'll
leave you to ponder over the
possibilities let me know what you think
in the comments section